talk about a big year for you like
personally and professionally how's it
feel number one having all this
recognition right now crazy I've dreamt
of doing this my whole life and to see
everything that's happening and to see
literally my dreams come true is
unbelievable and hard for me to put into
words yeah and the tour how's that going
awesome
I'm currently out with my buddy Russell
Dickerson on our first co-headlining
tour it's called the way back to her and
I'm going to jump off of that go
overseas and do some shows and then I'm
out all summer and fall with Jason
Aldean Cain Brown busy so I stopped that
stuff what's the last thing that it was
so cool because the two of you guys kind
of started around the same time you come
up together you you've been such close
friends and now you're both hitting this
massive stride at the same time do you
feel that same way about your
relationship with him I do I think it's
really special to be able to cheer on
your friends and to also see the
successes parallel in the way that he
and I our careers have and we met each
other ten years ago in a small club in
Nashville and shared a show bill
together when nobody was there and to be
able to do it now and hear people
singing all the words to our songs is
crazy that's nice do you ever take a
moment to just sit back and think about
where you came from
and and that girl who was dreaming and
trying to make it like what would you
say to her oh so many things I wish I
could hug her and just tell her that
it's gonna be okay because I moved here
ten years ago and it has not been easy
but I think also just that the music
that she loves
I loved true country music when I was
little the same people who influenced me
then the ladies of the 90s they
influenced me now and I would just tell
her that she'll get to make the music
that she wants and be the artist that
she always wanted to be does it feel
really cool to you to know that you know
as a as a female artist for what you
represent in country music for who
you're performing for that you could be
inspiring the next generations of greats
coming up as well yeah I think about
that sometimes and think about
just some of my my friends who are
starting out and saying that I'm helping
pave the way for them in the way that I
feel Kelsey did for me or Marian did for
me it's a really special and humbling
feeling to think that you're helping to
change especially for the females of
country and I hope to have a really long
legacy of being one of the ladies that
forever change country music yeah um how
has planning for a wedding affected how
you write your music do you have time to
do both at the same time we talked to
Michael he was like I'm kind of
hands-off with the planning I'm not
doing a whole lot I'm letting them do it
this and he said to us that he thinks
it's gonna be like a small intimate
thing is he correct he is correct yes he
is right we had to make a decision it's
hard when you both are in the music
industry we're gonna make it about our
friends and family and the people that
know us the closest and know it's the
best it's very interesting to be out on
the road as much as I am working on my
second record and getting married on the
same year but it's fun and I think it
each area of what's happening for me has
helped to shine light on what I'm doing
right now which is working on my second
record and getting engaged has been a
huge part of that and obviously with my
new single closer to you that's just the
start of this record but I think it's
also the start of chapter 2 which is
finding love yeah do you find that
you're less and less nervous as you move
forward putting out more songs putting
out another album into the world like
just kind of nervous about the idea of
of people hearing your music less
nervous no yeah more confident in the
fact that I have a place in country
music yes more confident in the fact
that I feel people are embracing me yes
and that's a really powerful and sweet
thing to think I feel like I was nervous
with every little thing because I wasn't
sure how that was gonna be perceived and
and if people were gonna listen and and
want to hear it and now I feel nervous
but excited because I know that people
have loved on me in a way that I've
dreamt of forever so excited